[Music]
uh so a father
is very ashamed of his son
sorry
[Laughter]
allergies allergies the frito dust got
in my nose that's like father's day
i thought i hit a dark spot in my life
oh father
uh so a father is very very very very
ashamed of his son what happened why is
he ashamed wow that's it
is it because his son came out as gay
and his dad doesn't accept it no why
would that happen that's true it's a new
era what his dad's getting is a closet
gay and he's in a kevin spacey movie is
that it no
aggressive that's cool that's cool no
the answer is no
uh the sun is a shame oh it's an asian
family and he got a c on his report card
it is an asian family
is there a son his son
is roommates with two chicks and he's
wondering why he never had a threesome
with them go fish because that's
actually real that's what his dad told
him yeah my dad told me uh that i was
gay because i had two girl roommates and
then i didn't have a threesome with them
yeah you [ __ ] you are that's what he
said damn dude he's projecting hard huh
yeah help with you dude i don't know
missed opportunity so why didn't you
yeah what happened well that boyfriend i
think oh oh
so i guess you did too
your dad was right
it's so limitations
he's not a go-getter
so roadblocks block your road
or i was just gay he was right uh a uh
father in china who apparently tried to
kill himself said that he was ashamed
that his son was still single at the age
of 29. wait so he tried to kill himself
because his son was still single he
collapsed at a train station and then
told everyone that it was a suicide
attempt
um well he survived what was thought to
be a suicide attempt based on the people
who saw he laid himself on a train
tracks yeah he survived that oh for that
reason huh that's great 29 is not that
[ __ ] the father that's all i gotta say i
don't know yeah i don't know about that
you can go die so he
so he handed he should have finished his
job he handed a note to a guards to a
group of guards at the shanghai railway
station
on january the 22nd and said he had just
overdosed on a medication then he
fainted on the spot
and the note addressed to his son
as a goodbye now
he wrote that he lived a life of shame
because his son had not yet
started a family for the report people
of my age in my village have all have
children they all have grandchildren
but you're 29 and have achieved nothing
right what in the note if he says in my
village i think that's where the thing
stops yeah the guy's from a village
what's he doing in shanghai yeah the
world moved on yeah it's a shanghai
village he also reportedly thought that
the subway was a dragon and he tried to
attack it oh so he just [ __ ] dumped a
homeless man no
i don't know what the [ __ ] are you
talking about so just because he's a
village he can't [ __ ] hate his son
he's just saying everybody in my village
like already had children by this age
but like we're already in a progressive
time where people are having children
lit or getting married later or maybe
not having as many children at all but
is that true in china though you wish
you knew he this is like
hey you know everyone's [ __ ] judging
my ass dude everyone's gonna be going
what the [ __ ] did you do who are you
backing up right now
this guy the dad yeah this guy yeah okay
i just want i just want the camera to
know that
let the white guy talk about this let's
go hey why are you playing daddy's
advocate daddy's advocacy of the chinese
village man look as a white man i'm very
offended by this
so you have to respect that [ __ ]
how old are you huh i'm 36 and do you
have children no your dad should [ __ ]
kill himself
dude my dad's tried
that's what this is about he just didn't
have a shanghai railway conveniently
played for a dragon there's an ab track
though in san diego
so he tried to uh take a bunch of
medication to kill himself yeah
and then he gave the note to the guard
he overdosed on medication handing it
out to the guards and then the note
revealed but he's a failure because he
tried two ways to kill himself when he
still didn't win he couldn't just leave
the note on a sunday idiot yeah room or
something
what does the sun have to say out of all
this i want to talk to the sun yeah they
didn't interview the sun because they
suck at reporting
my dad's a [ __ ] loser yeah
james cage white he's my age
and he just barely got married
did she leave initially during the
wedding earlier
you recently got married
barely recently got married
by a [ __ ] dude like the wedding was
at 3 30 they got married at 6 45 and she
she had like a lot of issues and she she
got married with mascara running down
her face
it was a close call but they made it
worse it's you mad yeah yeah
one witness yeah
i remember his instagram was super
depressing for like three years because
he kept talking about how he couldn't
get a girlfriend [ __ ] he keeps saying go
on dates and i'm like i don't like this
girl or this girl don't like me
we are not a connection
yeah i don't know i don't know maybe
it's a big [ __ ] deal out there
like everybody roasts the [ __ ] out of
you and you get social shame i don't
know i'm not chinese if a dad who thinks
a train's a dragon speaks for the
culture true he tried to kill it
he aimed for the heart and he missed
one shot and he hit the conductor that's
right
because a [ __ ] oracle told him that
if your son's a loser you must fight a
dragon to restore the honor of the fans
right yeah
he may not be an indicator his dad is uh
projecting on a son that's what's
happening a little bit do you guys give
family pressure to like hurry up and do
[ __ ] like have kids not if the older
sibling has already done it oh
so that's the key okay you have if you
have siblings and they do it then they
they back off you get way less pressure
yeah because my i only have one uh
sibling who is an older sister and she
is about to have her third child and is
married
for me it makes it so easy oh yeah
because
in my family there's so many [ __ ]
nieces nephews i don't know all their
names bro are you
the oldest or not i'm the oldest son hmm
but you have an older sister i have a
little sister who's hot as [ __ ]
but she already pumped out all the
grandkids yeah i mean dude yeah every
guy is slamming her there's so many
followers oh no
do your brothers have any kids uh yeah
my little my littlest brother has
now three on his third kid
she's about to pop like within so so
that means somebody's already carrying
on the green name though big time yeah
the big green not right in my opinion
not right they're not doing them well
they're not doing it well they're
[ __ ] up but i guess as a grandparent
it's kind of like all right the names
carried on i have grandchildren i've
been able to see them in my lifetime i'm
satisfied to an extent because it can't
be like all [ __ ] rainbows and
unicorns right yeah
so i mean i i for one reason i guess i
can understand the father being like
slightly ashamed sure i think it's
reasonable to feel some sort of shame
but not to the point of [ __ ] trying
to commit suicide twice in fact 29 is
young
in our generation that's what i'm saying
yeah yeah right
yeah his generation village generation i
understand but
when they get married 16
probably 15 16. oh man all i know is i
see nikki's grandma she's a filipino
lady
and every time i'm like
it's a total [ __ ] takeover
[Laughter]
what does she say
i don't know what she said
[Laughter]
oh is that what you think it means yeah
he's [ __ ] gentrifying the [ __ ]
limo family dude i wasn't even i wasn't
even thinking like that what were you
thinking of like about how i take over
the buffet table i got a big bib on is
nikki i think he's not full filipino
though she's she's half filipino oh so
that's already been taken over slightly
it's only halfway there yeah but no but
the best part is all the cousins and me
we're all white dudes so we're just in
there [ __ ] waffle style but the whole
heritage
[Laughter]
so everybody in that family married
white everybody bro wow they look
they're trying to give their children a
head start man and we're all big [ __ ]
it down dude
that is offensive yeah
but i like it we're double-digging at
some of us yeah
whoa
why people are born with two dicks
sometimes that's when i that's what i'm
[ __ ] my wife and then i'm also
[ __ ] around with my with my fingers
why are we
just rubbing it
i don't know what where are we at this
in this joke where are we i don't know
are we near the end of her mouth with my
fingers
i would have thought that's what you
meant
we're double digging you get pressure
you since you've been married and been
together for a long time my sisters
they're older
six and seven years now
i'm the only one that's married out of
like our whole west coast side were you
being pressured not to marry
no i don't think they really kind of
give a [ __ ] really wow which is kind of
weird like they don't talk about my
mom's like i'm not ready for grandkids
she's not ready for grandkids where the
[ __ ] says that i don't know i don't know
i don't know anybody that said i've
never heard that
ability you just get all the fun parts
yeah my mom's like
i'm not ready for this yet that's what
she says
she said that to us a couple nights ago
and i was like cool it's like somebody's
saying i don't want any dessert yeah who
the [ __ ] says that yeah yeah who doesn't
want dessert i said that i'm sorry i'm
not ready to win the lottery i don't
know
is there a savory dessert i'll leave
them that's the vibe of my family though
that's crazy i used to feel the pressure
all the time but not anymore does your
mom know that your sister's a less
though she's lessened out big time yeah
does your mom accept that
you know
kind of she's not ready for grandkids
because of that or no it's well as far
as like
my my oldest sister she's not really
dating anybody my middle sister she's
dating somebody but they live in miami
and they're kind of like i don't think
they want to have kids yeah so it's
literally just between me and my lady
but we're not in a rush either so for me
if i have a daughter and she's like hey
dad i'm a lesbian
i'll be like that that's totally fine
but i need you to [ __ ] prove it
like make out with your girlfriend right
now you see you make it with oh that's
that's too easy yeah but she needs to be
a hot girlfriend
and i'm your father
there's
so many ways my emotions don't accept
you what are your what are your emotions
are you feeling yeah what's going on
about the father-son complex after this
conversation cause we're just talking
about how lesbian we're talking about
how cool we are
to you guys that the father-son
complexes are the most powerful
emotional ties
whether it be in scripted things or in
real life for you actually yeah anytime
i hear about you know things like this
it it goes a little bit deeper you know
what i mean we're talking about how
lesbian relationships are super
beautiful and we're talking about how
you need your daughter as a lesbian to
prove it by making out with a hot chick
he needs a fact checking man
that's pretty progressive this story
that's pretty progressive yeah
as ridiculous as it sounds still
resonate with you in some way it's only
ridiculous because he failed to kill
himself twice
because of the dragons
yeah this guy's the dragon part doesn't
sound ridiculous the funny thing is
these [ __ ] they're such a narcissist
right that they make it their kid's
fault instead of having a hand in that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that went down exactly
that's your son he's probably got your
ugly ass [ __ ] face
you know
do we got a face shot of this ugly dad
ugly as [ __ ] dude and then i see a
picture and i'm like oh that that's the
mom for sure that's the mom damn i feel
bad you know
[Music]
you